joe biden has now been in office for 14
months inflation is at 40-year highs gas
prices have hit all-time highs we're
witnessing the first major war in europe
in 70 years some people believe we're
all on the brink of world war iii and to
top it all off there's not enough food
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
the food shortages are going to be real
he says
as though that's just a normal thing in
america
food shortages something that we have
not had in this country in what
90 plus years i'm thinking what the
great depression was that the last time
even then food shortages in the richest
most powerful country in the history of
the world
and a president who just sort of shrugs
it off like that's normal
we managed to survive biden's winter of
sickness and death just to find
ourselves in the springtime of famine
and hunger can you even imagine what
biden's got planned for summer
over the past two years things that we
never thought could happen in this
country have become realities seemingly
overnight
full-scale lockdowns church
closures federally mandated muzzles an
economy that just stops now food
shortages as we stare down the barrel of
a great power war in europe
i am no fan of barack obama but even a
stopped clock is right twice a day
obama was dead on the money about one
thing
we should never underestimate joe's
ability to f things up
i'm so glad you liked that clip now ring
the bell subscribe
make sure you get the notifications and
also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review if you haven't watched it
yet you've got to watch fouchy unmasked
the three-part docu-series at
dailywire.com we'll see you there
[Music]
[Music]